today's storyline of course is the final
game of alex gordon's career oh and we
forgot to add mike matheny has
designated alex to be manager for the
days there he goes
he will take the field
by himself
and folks i wish you were here today to
watch this magnificent 14-year career
come to an end he will be playing in his
1753rd game brady singer and brady
will be making start number three
three out of his 12 this year will be
against the tigers now they're two men
out the batter brandon dixon
he drives one to deep center
back goes oliveiras and he's going to
play it off the wall
cameron was on the move he will score
easily and brandon dixon has his first
hit of the season it's an rbi double to
give detroit the early lead yeah the
charge has ever been presented by mgm
grand detroit it's only his third game
he's had injury problems this year
3-2 to gordon and he struck him out to
start the day
it's the payoff and a wave and a miss
jordan zimmerman a couple of punch-outs
here in the first in the royal strand a
two-out single from alberto mondesse
bottom of the first alex gordon leads
off
will this be his blasted bat alex awaits
the 3-2 pitch
here it is
and he swings and misses a fastball down
and away so down goes alex
here comes the change franchi cordero is
going to go to right
wood mirrorfield is going to go to left
and that's going to be it ironically
alex's first at-bat was a strikeout his
last at-bat was a strikeout but there
were 14 years of thrills in between
there's his family from a private suite
just above us of course we didn't know
they were going to pull him out but he
being the
manager for the day he has the card
there is a swing and a flare towards
center field and a great diving catch by
nikki lopez who takes a base hit away
from victor reyes for out
number two
the 01 to him
sends one to left
is he inning for bonifacio when he makes
a very nice play right near the wall
here's the o2
this one driven to right cameron's got a
beat on it
and the royals go quietly in the third
swing and a miss he does get his first
strikeout and it comes on a good 94 mile
an hour fastball
there's a swing ground ball modesty
picks it off fielding on the right side
of the diamond and throws out stewart
the royals only hit came from the guy
who's now standing at home plate that is
alberto modesty
oh and he gets on top of one and drives
it deep to left field and adelberto
mondesi
is going out with a flourish
that is a line drive wind cutting home
run to left field and the royals have
tied the game in the fourth inning wow
off the knuckles and dozier takes care
of bonifacio
and there's one down in the fifth inning
brady singer
has retired 12 in a row
that is a swing and down goes hosse and
they're two away one and two on ryan
mcgroom
ryan mcbroom hits one into deep left
field and that is going to put the
royals in front
ryan mcbroom hits his sixth home run of
the season
and to mcbroom's stature that's his
sixth homer already
on a slider
on the ground to lopez
out at second monday high throw dozier
keeps his foot on the bag
and the royals get a double play
and a swing and a miss and brady gets
another strikeout
swing and a miss and brady singer wow
the singer throwing machine strikes out
kristen stewart he has five strikeouts
for the ball game he's allowed just one
run
go
drives it to right cameron was shallow
and that is going to be over his head
and monday will stop at second base with
a double but he'll drive in a run
he's certainly with a wet track like
this look at that fastball that's going
the other way folks a lot of guys want
to pull that monday he already showed
you his power he pulled one there's no
way he's catching that one
and hud that is base hit
number 12 in this four game series
tying george brett's team record back in
75 against the angels
jesse is
going for his second save
of this series
a called third strike
and that's it for the royals
in
2020
they finish their final home stand at
five and two
and they end up winning 12 for their
last 18 games
ryan mcbroom gets the game-winning rbi
today that was a tie-breaking
solo home run in the fifth inning
and on the day that alex gordon is
celebrated
and ends his 14-year career all in a
royals uniform
the royals win 3-1